يستمر الحداد الإسرائيلي حتى مع
تزايد الضجيج حول رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو، الذي يتساءل
عما إذا كانت سياساته ساعدت في دعم
حماس، في سلسلة من المقابلات مع
لاعبين إسرائيليين رئيسيين، قيل لقناة سي إن إن
ومنصة التحقيق الإسرائيلية
كيف سمح نتنياهو بتبرعات نقدية قطرية
لحماس لسنوات.  بدون
إشراف على الرغم من المخاوف من داخل
حكومته، 30 مليون دولار
شهريًا، حسنًا،
360 مليونًا، إنها أكثر من مليار، هذه
عملية حسابية بسيطة، إنها
أموال كثيرة، أموال كثيرة، الدولار في غزة
يشبه 20 دولارًا فينا بالنسبة لهم، كان ذلك بمثابة
راحة لهم  كان مثل
الأكسجين، هل يمكنك العيش بدون أكسجين، لا، لذا
فهو خطأ تاريخي دراماتيكي يقول
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي السابق ووزير
الدفاع السابق نفتالي بينيت
إنه كان من بين أولئك الذين
أثاروا المخاوف بشكل متكرر لنتنياهو عندما
أصبح بينيت رئيسًا للوزراء في عام 2021، وقد
وضع حدًا للقضايا القضائية  تحويل الأموال النقدية إلى
حماس، نقل تحويل
الدعم المالي إلى حماس من الأموال النقدية إلى
آلية تابعة للأمم المتحدة، أقوم بتخزين الحقائب النقدية
لأنني أعتقد أن
السماح لكماس بالحصول على كل هذه
الحقائب مليئة بالنقود، والذي يذهب
مباشرة إلى إعادة تسليح أنفسهم ضد
الإسرائيليين، هو خطأ فادح، لماذا  هل سنطعمهم نقودًا
لقتلنا، كان من
المفترض أن تساعد المساعدات النقدية، من بين
الاحتياجات الإنسانية الأخرى، في دفع رواتب موظفي الخدمة المدنية في غزة،
وأظهرت الصور في عام 2018
العمال وهم يصطفون للحصول على أوراق نقدية بقيمة 100 دولار،
ووافقت إسرائيل على الصفقة في
اجتماع لمجلس الوزراء الأمني ​​في أغسطس 2018 خلال اجتماع
سابق.  نياهو تينيا كرئيس للوزراء،
دافع مسؤول إسرائيلي عن
قرار نتنياهو قائلاً لشبكة سي إن إن إن الحكومات الإسرائيلية المتعاقبة
مكنت الأموال من الذهاب إلى غزة
ليس من أجل تعزيز حماس ولكن
لمنع حدوث أزمة إنسانية، هذا
صحيح ولكن لم يوافق أحد على ذلك نقدًا.
يقول رئيس الوزراء السابق بينيت إن
نتنياهو استهان بحماس أعتقد
أه النهج تجاه حماس كان من
النوع المزعج أه
منظمة إرهابية يمكنها إطلاق الصواريخ يمكن أن
تسبب القليل من الخراب هنا وهناك ولكن
ليس أكثر من ذلك بكثير قلل من شأنها
وبالتأكيد أه وأه في  بهذا
المعنى، تعلمنا الدرس الذي
يجب أن نصدقه أعداءنا، لقد أصبح هذا الدرس
نقطة تحول بالنسبة لإسرائيل،
حتى أن حلفاء نتنياهو القدامى الذين يحبون
عبر هاور يعترفون بأن ذلك
كان درسًا استراتيجيًا للمجتمع الإسرائيلي
حيث يمكنك التحدث كثيرًا عن
السلام.  يمكنك محاولة القيام بالكثير من الأشياء،
يمكنك القدوم إلى البيت الأبيض
للحصول على بعض جوائز نوبل
ولكن في مرحلة ما يكفي ذلك،
وإذا سألتني ما الذي يرمز إليه يوم
7 أكتوبر، الذي يرمز إليه في الغالب
للمجتمع الإسرائيلي لا  المزيد يخاطرون بمخاطرات
كهذه في ظل
المعاناة الإنسانية والدعوات الدولية
لإبطاء قصف غزة قبل أن
تقتنع إسرائيل بأن حماس قد تم تدميرها
مهما كان الثمن.